cool bit of news Doctor Who has just  picked up a Guinness World Record well  more specifically one of the performers  in it that would be William Russell who  now holds the Guinness record for  longest gap between appearances as the  same character This Record was  previously 43 years held by Philip  Laurie over on Coronation Street William  Russell resumed his role as Ian  Chesterton 57 years over 57 years since  the last time he appeared this is not  Doctor Who's only standing record it  also holds the record for longest  running fiction TV show and most  successful Sci-Fi TV show and before  some of you start coming at me going  what about Star Trek Guinness counts  every individual Star Trek show as its  own show whereas Doctor Who is counted  as one continuous thing because remember  it was not canceled in 89 it was put on  a very long Hiatus so congratulations to  William congratulations to the show  it was good to have you back